you know when we're dealing with
creating health and fighting off health
problems it's not just one food It's a
combination of foods So today we're
going to talk about one additional food
that I think you should add
to your daily salads and that is the
lonely carrot now I've done past videos
on carrots relating to the ketogenic
diet but not necessarily the health
properties of carrots and I recently
stumbled on some data that is quite
fascinating carrots can actually do more
for your health than you might think now
the first thing that usually comes up
with a carrot is that it's generally
sweet so people are avoiding those
because they're trying to avoid carbs on
the ketogenic diet and it is true that
the glycemic index of a carrot is about
72 so high is starting at 70. so it's 72
so yeah it's a little bit high but
because it's so filled with fiber okay
and the net carbs for one medium carrot
is only 4.3 carbs
and you're allowed like 50 carbs is
false in the category of something
that's pretty safe because the glycemic
load which is a little different than
the glycemic index is a different
formula it's basically the amount of
carbs because we're deducting all this
fiber brings the carrot down to like a
2.8 on the glycemic load scale I mean
think about this anything less than 10
is low it's pretty low on the glycemical
load so you're not going to bump
yourself out of ketosis by eating a
carrot a day carrots typically are
thought of improving your eyesight
because they're loaded with the
precursor to vitamin A and beta-carotene
which is the precursor is not retinol
the active form of vitamin A even though
they call it vitamin A it's a precursor
it has to be converted and there's a
small percentage that can convert to
retinol it's not that high but it's
something now there are a lot of other
things in carrots you have all sorts of
phytonutrients that help as as a general
antioxidant so let's get into it number
one the fiber in carrots that we can't
digest but our microbes can
can greatly help you detoxify estrogen
okay and so if you're estrogen dominant
it can help balance that now what are
the risk factors of estrogen dominance
well problems with your menstrual cycle
heavy periods weight gain in a lower
section of your body increased risk of
cancer and so anything that can actually
buffer this estrogen is a good thing
number two it lessens the activation of
pro carcinogens those are things that
are like carcinogenic things that can
cause cancer well they lessen the
activation of that number three it's an
antioxidant number four it's
anti-angiogenic what does that mean
well when a cancer cell grows it needs
blood supply and so there are various
vegetables
definitely the cruciferous vegetables
but also carrots that can inhibit these
new blood vessels to tumors thus are
called
anti-angiogenic carrots also have
anti-clotting properties they also have
properties that can help fight
mycoplasmas which are bacteria without
the cell wall but I think one of the
biggest benefits of carrots
is related to this other phytonutrient
and it's called fall caranol now there
is some data that shows that it's not
just this one phytonutrient there's some
other related synergistic compounds but
nonetheless if you eat a raw carrot a
day you're going to get a good amount of
this volcano and volcano is a natural
pesticide
and fungicide volcano is also into
phenyl it's in celery it's in ginseng
it's in parsley
but there's a lot of it in carrots now
even though it's a natural pesticide
it's not harmful to our bodies so you
don't have to worry about it in fact it
may help you if you have any pathogenic
funguses growing in your body but the
big thing that fall carinol does is what
it can do for cancer apparently the
research shows that it can significantly
decrease the risk of cancer especially
breast cancer and prostate cancer and
gastric cancer and maybe even other
Cancers and this other function May
relate to cancer or just in general it
just may help you with inflammation
because volcanol is a potent inhibitor
of intestinal inflammation even more
than sulforaphane and I've done videos
on this where I talked about
sulforaphane helping with gastritis and
all sorts of inflammation in your gut
and sulforaphane is in broccoli and
broccoli Sprouts but we don't want to
forget the carrot too okay so I would
recommend eating one at least 1
medium-sized Raw carrot Organic Raw
carrot in your salad or just in general
each day and one of the ways that it can
do this is through stimulating the tumor
suppressor genes and these are things
that can actually suppress the genetics
that relate to Growing tumors in some of
these studies which I'll list down below
you get a slower development of the
cancer you get inhibition of the
aggressive cancer cells you also get
induction of apoptosis what does that
mean it means that it triggers the
cancer cells to die now since we're on
the topic of cancer okay in foods you
should definitely see this video that
related to other foods you should be
eating to lower your risk of cancer and
I put that up right here